21 year old making his 13th start 19th
appearance remember he faced the rockies
on july 11th
when he made the start in the first half
of the finale two innings do that
ankle injury was out of the game he is
ready to go stepping up to the plate
right now tapia he'll lead it off
soft ground ball headed out to
cronenberg out number one
one down in the first brendan rogers
to the two hopper and a bounding ball to
tatis
it's two outs in the first inning
this is to left and toward that corner
and it gets away from adam frazier who's
more of a second baseman crone coming
home
and he will score one-nothing colorado
this ball comes up once it it hits off
the warning track
it looks like it comes back and hits
frazier in the head oh the ball got
stuck
that's what it was in question but here
but here once you go in to reach for it
though it's still a live ball
if he would have thrown his hands up so
it is second and third
the run does not score that loads him up
it's a second walk in his first inning
diaz draws a walk now they're loaded up
and it'll be a left on left
match up ryan mcmahon this ball is hit
pretty well left center field hit really
well how about a grand slam
that'll work for nothing colorado
right back 17th it had been since
june 15th and if you're going to end the
drought
and did it grand fashion well
and you know it was a long way out there
when you're looking at the center field
there's
mack has his first career grand slam he
took a couple courtesy steps that was it
and john gray making his second start on
this road trip he went
five innings on sunday in l.a got a no
decision gave
up two runs in five in england one out
fernando at first and manny machado
coming up
to third pick by mcmahon no he's gonna
drop it on the transfer
heading for third is fernando and he'll
be out
and he gets hurt on the play taboo
so fernando is out at third base but
clutching onto his arm
after the slide attempt all eyes on
fernando tatis junior at petco park in
san diego right now rogers is there
and is his left shoulder again maybe
that shoulder again
just kind of hyper extended so the last
thing anybody
wants to see among the friar faithful is
this two down
four nothing colorado top of the second
inning
wow i don't know see if they challenge
it
hosmer thought they should skip
schumacher on the phone
challenge ryan weathers one of the best
moves in baseball as a lefty
real hesitation out
and he is indeed out so picked off
weathers gets another one
elias diaz coming up next
line and caught ha sung kim
up into the air a liner and hassam kim
times his lead perfectly and here's
trent grisham this center fielder
one and one on trent grisham
[Applause]
to third mcmahon one out
he's got some movement on his fastball
tonight absolutely does
pitch from gray and that one's tapped to
the left side john off the mound
bare hand pickup throws to first in
plenty of time
make it five straight ground ball outs
for john gray
two down in the third next pitch is hit
up the middle but right there is brendan
rodgers to grab it and he throws onto
first
another one two three inning three more
ground ball outs for john gray
lead off man over at first mcmahon
here's connor joe the rockies
left fielder one-two pitch is hit high
and deep to left field
back on the ball frazier it is over and
out of here
home run for connor joe
rocky's lead six to nothing not only
is that connor's second big league
home run it's his first home run in his
hometown and what a thrill that is
for the rookie and here's brendan
rodgers
this ball hit to deep left brendan
rodgers
has hit it off the glove of adam frazier
topia is going to score it looks like it
may hit off of frazier's glove
well and then maybe off of a fan too
well let's hope that's the case because
then it'll be a two-run home
it hit off with two gloves and the
second glove
is a young man who's in the stands
now he brought his glove
[Music]
exactly reached up the ball's coming his
direction
rocky's up eight nothing john great
fourth inning now hassan kim with a 2-2
count he's gone he strikes out
two down and machado at first brings up
will myers
2-1 this is popped up left side
foul ground mcmahon oh
still make the catch almost over ran it
turns into a heck of a play chris mott
will get
elias diaz ryan mcmahon and connor joe
oh one breaking ball hit well to left
field how about
home run number four touch him all time
for
elias diaz his tenth of the year
nine nothing rockies that's corey little
on the right
in the green shirt who is the
outstanding head of media relations for
the rockies
and the young man got really upset
because he felt like
he had done something wrong which he
didn't no and and
corey because we saw he brought uh
a bunch of items rocky's items i'm sure
the young man's a padre fan but
he brought a bunch of items and uh look
at that
he's been speaking with him literally
and his family for the last several
minutes
the padres so far behind he's going to
hit for himself
leading off to six pitch swing and a
miss got him to chase the slider way out
of the strike zone
and john gray gets strikeout number four
that'll get mandy to the plate here for
the third time machado
on a line down the left field line gone
line drive two-run home run is 19th of
the year the padres are on the board
just like to get john through this
seventh inning
myers hits a towering fly ball to left
connor joe under control
so osborne a third two outs will get a
pinch hitter
high fly ball to the left connor joe
has got it good job by kenley he gets
the next two
one on one out and here comes the guy
that got that home run
two run shot high fly ball to deep lift
center field for
machado that ball's gone into the moped
second home run of the night for manny
another two home run here come the
padres
grisham bowdoin can get him he'll be out
number 27
3-2 and this is playable
left side ruiz again and he makes the
catch in foul groud and that's the ball
game
[Applause]